wait a second you just said I as in you
you like poison running
as what you do the cast of The
Descendants have come so far since we
first saw them on the small screen today
we're revealing their journey from
humble beginnings to stardom and we've
saved the best for last so stay tuned
Audrey actress saira Jaffrey who plays
the role of Audrey in The Descendants
films got her big break playing the role
of sandy Newton's on-screen daughter on
DIRECTV's Road after that she booked the
role of Audrey in the first descendants
film and although she wasn't indie - she
stayed pretty busy she played the role
of Jennifer Lopez's daughter Christina
Santos in the series shades of blue now
after d3 she landed a role on charmed as
Maggie the mind reader
that's quite a journey Hades you might
have seen the actor who plays Hades in
the popular series American Horror Story
but did you know that Cheyenne Jackson
was also in 30 rock and glee before that
that's right pre AHS and pre descendants
three Cheyenne Jackson played a dude
with a funny laugh who annoyed Tina Fey
and a snarky teacher Inc Lee then he
went on to act with Lady gaga an
American Horror Story and eventually
came to be the god of the underworld in
descendants three Cheyenne is currently
acting in the new series stellar people
as a handsome cop let's start at the
very beginning dizzy before her role as
dizzy Germain in descendants Anna
Cathcart starred as Olympia in odd squad
the movie after that she went on to
become the stylist with the most unique
and incredible flair in descendants -
and descendant 3 since wrapping up d3
Anna has gone on to star in Netflix's -
all the boys I've loved before and also
the TV series Fastlane additionally Anna
is playing the title character in the TV
series Zoe Valentine Anna started out at
the fan of the first descendants movies
just like us her story is a reminder
that dreams really do come true
Celia Jada Marie Johnson who plays the
role of Celia and descendants three has
had a passion for acting as long as she
can remember she started competing in
cheer in gymnastics when she was four
years old she even won three national
titles and cheer as a flyer she also
does stand-up comedy
but her favorite thing to do is give to
charity helping less fortunate children
in group and foster homes she is just
getting started with her role in
descendants 3j for booboo Stewart The
Descendants films are just a portion of
his well-rounded achievements he got his
start as a model in 2010 he played Seth
Clearwater in the Twilight films which
really launched his acting career he
also received a record deal at the age
of 12 with Walt Disney Records and as
toured with the Jonas Brothers Miley
Cyrus and the Cheetah Girls he also
worked as a stunt person on the movie
Beowulf in 2007 he's definitely on a
majorly powerful career path since d3 he
has already been in a dozen films and TV
shows may be a little rusty but I can
handle a bo staff very hook Disney's
descendants two and three have been
life-changing for Thomas Dougherty after
all he met the love of his life dove
Cameron on the set of these films he has
certainly come a long way from his role
of street boy in NBC's Dracula in 2013
and after his role of Harry hook and d2
he starred in the British drama series
the lodge and it just so happens that
his girlfriend dev was also on the show
since production has ended on
descendents three Thomas landed a role
on the HBO miniseries Catherine the
Great so he's not slowing down anytime
soon
uma china anne mcclain is no stranger to
the bright lights of film and TV she
started as a kid on house of pain and
she was totally adorable then she went
on to play the role of Chyna parks in
Disney's ant farm
interestingly Chyna started on Disney's
animated show descendants wicked world
playing someone different than her
on-screen role the aisle will rise and I
promise
she voiced the character Freddy
faciliate before she went on to star in
d2 as uma then she became thus evil and
we all loved and went on to give mal
trouble in descendants three so what is
she up to now if you miss her after The
Descendants movies are over don't worry
you can catch her as Jennifer Pierce on
CW's Black Lightning Carlos
Cameron voice got his start as a wee lad
in a panic at the disco music video
since then he starred in several films
and TV shows including grown ups one in
two and the ultimate spider-man but his
career really began to sizzle when he
joined forces with Disney on the hit
show live in Maddy which stars another
descendants actor by the name of dub
Cameron that explains the tight
friendship between dub and Cameron ever
since he starred in the first
descendants movie he has kept his
schedule busy with other Disney projects
such as Jesse and bunked after d3
Cameron has gone on to star in the TV
series Paradise City among other
exciting projects Evie Sofia Carson's TV
career began when she appeared in
Disney's Austin & Ally she went on to
star in MTV's TV series faking it before
landing the role of Evie and Disney's
descendants after that she cut her first
album with Walt Disney Records and even
performed on stage at Coachella since
her appearance in The Descendants films
she's been a busy lady she voiced the
role of Kimia aka sand girl in the
animated series spider-man she played
the role of Ava in Pretty Little Liars
additionally she starred alongside Ron
Perlman and Dominique Swain in Asbury
Park this princess is on fire don't make
it again now Duff Cameron got her start
as a Disney sweetheart in Liv and Maddie
since then the world has opened up and
made all of her dreams come true
Disney's descendants has definitely
changed her life because she met her
gorgeous boyfriend on set
yep that would be Thomas Doherty after
descendants stuff has gone on to star in
the Broadway musical clueless she also
voiced the role of Ella in the upcoming
Angry Birds 2 is equal we can't wait to
see what else the cast of The
Descendants movies does next if you love
the cast of descendants as much as we do
leave a purple villain emoji in the
comment section below don't forget to
subscribe and like this video to be the
first one to see our new
with vids on all things descendants have
a wicked cool day
[Music]